no that's not so easy with a gorgeous
bestie
that's sweetie with her gorgeous mom
you look so cute
and the whole thing is breaking the
internet it's icy goat 2.0 on thursday
the 28 year old rapper posted these
bathroom selfies to instagram that's the
musician rocking a plunging black dress
with a thigh-high slit posing next to
her mom trinidad valentin who slays in a
little black sequence number i really
love it and that that's the
mother-daughter duo serving some serious
face for the camera
sus mario subject on
[Music]
you look so cute
fans swarmed to the comments to point
out that the two look more like sisters
than mother daughter calling trinidad
stunning adding quote ain't no way this
sweetie's mom sis looks 25 even paris
hilton chimed in writing quote whoa just
realized that is your mom thought that
was your sister hot mama and there's
legs
the pics were taken on wednesday night
before they hit up the billboard women
in music awards where the icy rapper
performed her hit closer
[Music]
she also accepted the 2022 game changer
award presented to her by who else you
guessed it her mom
i would like to take this time
to thank my mom
but this isn't the first time sweetie's
followers have fangirled over trinidad
back in 2020 the musician revealed her
mom was a video vixen back in the day
during an episode of her youtube series
the icy
she ain't been life the icy life yet but
it's my mom
and she act like she used to be wearing
this back in her day okay yeah trinidad
was in nellie's 2000 music video for
ride with me
and a video for dmx and cisco
bridget kathy rashida kelly fans were
surprised to learn that your mom was the
baddie in the nelly in bmx video have
she ever tells you any stories about
those days for her yeah she really did
my mom was telling me that video of
vixens actually were really respected
back in the days
they had booking agents they had super
high fees and
they were considered like just just
models like any other model that was out
there they were equivalent to that and
they would get booked on that rate and
then it's crazy because i ain't gonna
say no names because it's not for me to
do that but she shares the girls who
kind of effed it up for everybody who
are willing to work at a lower rate who
are willing to
you know
do crazy things for their roles and
that's how you know the value of the
video vixen went down but it used to
actually have a really good
connotation
from video vixen to hotmama one thing's
for sure this duo knows how to get the
internet talking
[Music]
you